kaylee mcinerney is the co-host of
outnumbered and former white house press
secretary and she joins me now thank you
for joining me today
good to join you ben
so tell me a little bit about what you
think of the left's efforts when it
comes to diminishing the role of moms
and dads within society and making child
rearing something that modern
professionals view as totally abhorrent
and something that would ruin your their
lives
ben what you just said uh was so
important um so often not spoken but a
message that everyone needs to hear it
is a subtle attack by the left you
nailed it you know it goes back to a
time when we all used to agree president
john f kennedy said children are
messages to a time that we will not see
you know i know that you are a new
father i'm a new mom
i was researching for this segment
before i went up to wake my daughter
baby blake from a nap and i was reading
quotes from aoc you mentioned her in
your monologue and she said is it okay
to have children in this day and age you
said that on an instagram live
vox went on to pontificate whether it's
ethical ethical to have children amid a
warming world climate change now used as
a reason to not have children look it's
every woman and man's decision whether
they want to make that decision to have
a child but if you have that desire in
your heart a few things come to mind
besides global warming that are
epidemics a pandemic a crime wave but
the left trying to now insert ethics
morality into the decision to have a
child a basic family unit and you
mentioned black lives matter of course
they used to have on their website the
family unit
was something that they were challenging
you were spot on it's a subtle message
being expressed that's not often talked
about you know kaylee the thing that is
so jarring to me
is that i hear from so many of my
friends who are successful who have the
resources who have the ability to have
children that they can't possibly think
about bringing a child into this world
and then i think about all the things
we've gone through in our history you
know that the children who came out of
the great depression the people who've
changed the world over the years have
come at incredibly difficult times in
the world what would your message be to
those who are concerned in this moment
you know men and women who say i just i
look around at all the horrible things
that are happening how can i bring a
child into this
my message would be exactly what you
said which is that freedom is at risk
that ronald reagan said it best freedom
is one generation away from extinction
uh and that is why we bring children
into this world to carry on the message
of the united states of america of your
family unit of your faith whatever that
may be carry on the values that we hold
dear and also there's the other
component to this ben and i saw it in
the white house as press secretary where
children now are being put last i had dr
scott atlas come into my office
topple on my desk a stack of papers and
say here is the data that our children
should be in schools all of the science
is there that shows that they're not
transmitting covet as readily why are we
as a country putting our children last
who what nation sacrifices their
children as western european countries
are opening their schools and we are not
as child abuse cases are reporting
rather is going down
cases and hospitals are going up it's
reported in schools and we're keeping
our school doors shut so there's the
idea of having kids and then there's the
idea of protecting those kids on the
other side we will look back i believe
at this pandemic and those decisions
where the rest of the world was able to
find a way to get kids back into school
and we were not as being an incredible
failure of governance thank you kaylee
for joining me tonight
thank you ben hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else